it's a busy morning at the Port now with
better weather conditions hundreds if
not thousands of migrants are trying
their luck across the Mediterranean
mothers hoping to give a better life to
their children young men wanting to
build a future
this group of friends started their
journey in Senegal
me now says the island got used to these
arrivals just a few days ago he
witnessed a boat landing on the beach
I don't know how they do it so many die
it's terrible a few years ago we caught
a body in our net and often we find
bones yesterday a boat arrived on the
beach there was a mother with her child
among them we gave them some food and
water I feel so sorry it's ugly to
witness
most of the boats get rescued or arrive
unaided to shore but there are also many
that capsize
migrants do take a gamble when they set
off in these overcrowded rickety boats
unfit to sail such a long journey and
often they found themselves in distress
in the middle of the sea with no land in
sight
vessels leaving Tunisia are made of iron
hastily solder together
the engines too small to power them and
by and large the only safety device the
migrants can rely on are inner tubes
the humanitarian rescue group Sea Watch
carries out surveillance flights in the
central Mediterranean the interceptions
in in this area were really getting more
and more in in the last years I would
say that people who are now taking this
route which is even more dangerous if if
you look into just the distance and and
the size of the Mediterranean Sea here
this is also a result by European
policies and and the the deterrence
um the European Union wants to put up
immersion vessel to rescue four people
including three miners who were drifting
in an open top vessel with no engine
they survived for four days they said
they were involved in a shipwreck 41
others remain unaccounted for
perhaps their bodies will wash off on
the coast of lampedusa like those who
are laid to rest here nestled among the
residents but this cemetery is at full
capacity and the latest victims of these
desperate Journeys still await a place
to finally rest
foreign